I think it's more than one reason why
adolescents are more at risk now first
and foremost is it's a stressful period
of time there are at least five
developmental tasks that you have to
accomplish some time before adolescence
ends and so adolescence begins when
puberty begins so it's a it's a real
sign it's a biological moment so for
boys it's pigmented pubic hair as soon
as you have pigmented pubic hair puberty
is started adolescence the count has
started you're supposed to finish your
adolescence in ten to twelve years and
for girls it's breast buds
so it's not having your menses and it's
not being able to have necessarily sperm
inside your semen it is those first
biological signs that show you puberty
and now we have the clock going and in
that time period there are five
stressful things that you have to
accomplish the first is you have to get
used to the physical changes of puberty
now anyone who has a recollection of
middle school and particularly bells
going off to end class from one period
to another and a boy who has a sexy
thought that goes through his head and
all of a sudden he gets aroused in a way
that he spends most of junior high
school or middle school with books in
front of his genitals as he's running
around you know from one class to
another or he gets a pimple or his nose
grows or a girl gets developed breasts
before anybody else does and being able
to adjust to those physical changes is
the first test the second is being able
to separate from mom and dad or your
Guardians and typically teenagers have
you know different tastes and music
different tastes in politics different
tastes in clothing and if we look at
billboards in the United States of
clothing whether it's Abercrombie and
and Fitch or if it's Calvin Klein
they are always adolescent or
pre-adolescent looking kids who are
looking at who have clothes that are
very different than the adults are
wearing so that when I was younger it
would you wore tight clothes when you're
a teenager when my kids became teenagers
they started wearing very baggy clothes
that were very different you know that
you know three people could fit into the
pair of pants and so moving away and
testing
those things and being able to have a
healthy separation is one of the
important parts which if you're healthy
have a healthy separation you can
actually eat with your mom and dad and
they can say something stupid and you
don't get excited because you realize
that they're separate from you the third
is the development of a social network
which for boys very often at younger
ages is about sports or hobbies and for
girls they're a little more
sophisticated they socialize in
concentric circles so the coolest kids
are in the middle but you might hang out
with the girl who's a very good athlete
on the hockey field and you might be
cool with the girl who's great math
student in math class and then next is
you have to have vocational or
educational goals so when you're younger
it might be US history but by the time
you're 22 or 23 you have to have some
idea of what you want to do with your
life and so someone who's 40 and has
never really had one career and it keeps
moving from one to another is being very
very adolescent and the last one is
sexual orientation so even if you've
never had physical intercourse the fact
is that by the time you're 23 22 24 you
should know what's turning you're
turning you on because the biggest sex
organ we have is between our ears it's
our brain and that's what we know is
turning us on or turning us off so
people say they're still looking for
themselves or exploring you know their
fluidity of their sexuality at 40 or 30
it's really being very adolescent so you
have those five developmental tasks
which are stressful but on top of that
you have these brain changes those two
things combined clearly makes the
teenage years not only filled with more
angst but clearly more risk for a real
depression
there's two areas that we should just
talk about and and one of them is what's
the big deal if you have depression and
if one doesn't accept how real these
disorders are one then does that at the
peril of the teenage patient or your
child if they're an adolescent and that
is or yourself because you can
understand why teenagers or adolescents
the mantra is I want to be the same I
want to be just like everyone else and
for the parent it's very often it's just
a phase
hopefully they'll outgrow it and the
danger for that is that if you get sick
when you're in high school and you are
too tired in the morning to wake up or
you can't concentrate or you don't have
the motivation to study you very quickly
will start to fail and you'll either
have to go to summer school or you'll be
kicked off the football team you'll lose
the coveted seat at the right table in
the cafeteria and very often you lose
out you're no longer on that on that
curve that everyone else is on and it's
very hard even if you get treatment to
get back up versus an adult who gets
sick who gets depression well what's the
big deal it'll take me a few weeks to
get well but if I don't go out for
dinner with my friends or I stop playing
tennis with the group of guys I play
tennis with you know nothing terrible
will happen they'll forgive me and I
won't get fired from my job and most
probably my wife won't leave me but my
girlfriend might if I was 16 years old
because I'm so grumpy and irritable and
so there's a tremendous cost and the
second piece is that teenagers when
they're depressed get hopeless and when
they get hopeless that's when they try
to hurt themselves and the fact that
five thousand teenagers kill themselves
every year between the ages of 14 and 24
in the United States is criminal as far
as I'm concern and the the leading cause
of death among teenagers is accidents
the second is homicide and the third is
suicide in New York by the way suicide
is number two because we can't get a
hold of handguns here so these are all
psychiatric outcomes because people who
have ADHD have
more car accidents and their car
accidents are three times more expensive
than kids who don't have it and people
who have depression are you know much
more likely not only to complete suicide
but to attempt suicide